pour il n'y a pas de doute ce qui va
ressortir libre et blanchi
oui en l'état de leurs connaissances
générant l'état de méconnaissance du
dossier et john parti qu'ils échappent
qui regardait sous boisseau secret par
les instruments les enquêteurs et
parquet mais c'est tout à fait normal
dans une affaire aussi grave que celle
ci il ne doute pas qu'il sera remis en
liberté est lavé de tout soupçon
mercredi matin ou marty soir m on peut
néanmoins penser que trois mois après
les faits si les enquêteurs ont entendu
trois mois six à gratter creuser c'est
qu'il doit y avoir des éléments
suffisants pour le mettre en garde les
enquêteurs le poker la république du
trim et la décoration de besançon le
juge d'instruction de ce guet métier
avait exigeante et grande expertise
technique dont les retours étaient
prévus entre 15 novembre et 15 janvier
une grande partie sont rentrés d'autres
il pense en cours de réalisation des
compléments d'enquêté demandée à la
suite de cette patrie des expertises et
je pense que je suis l'inscription
voulait être en possession de tous ses
résultats avant de placer monsieur
d'aval en garde certainement pour fermer
des portes et des pistes peut-être aussi
pour lui présenter des éléments qui
pourraient être plus non pas dérangeant
mais qui prend interpellé les enquêteurs
et sur lesquels ils ont besoin de ces
éclaircissements sur le trajet qui leur
est à la veille de la disparue sous
location alors mais la dispute
jeune ingénieur toute l'histoire du
trajet vous évoquez ce que je sais pour
l'avoir lu sous la plume de vos
collègues et confrères c'est qu'à priori
mal à me laval a été retrouvé en tête
chercheuse
donc c'est qu'elle est morte samedi donc
ce qu'a fait monsieur laval le vendredi
je les ignore mais je ne pense pas que
cela remette en cause le fait que madame
barral est décédé le samedi et la
vanille la dispute apparemment dès sa
première audition
ça il en avait parlé aux parents se
disputent ou en avoir des griffures voir
des morsures ça paraît pas logique j'ai
eu également cela dans la presse écrite
jean marc est a priori c'est lui qui en
a parlé spontanément alors que personne
n'en parlait vous savez comme moi que
dix ans de vie de couple
il ya des hauts et des bas et qu'on peut
se disputer avec la personne avec
laquelle on vit sans pour autant de
biens criminels sinon si chaque fois que
dans un couple aux disputes il s'ensuit
un mort la situation c'est tragique
donc il y avait certainement dans son
cou comme nous tous les coups les hauts
et les bas
que dire de ce voisin qui vient
d'entendre un bruit de plaques qui
détient la villa noailles sur deux
fonctions de jonathan alors l'année et
cette histoire de deux tunnels dont on a
trouvé des traces
j'ignore tout ce voisin mais vous savez
comme moi que les témoignages humains
sont souvent très fragile voit dans la
cour d'assises ya souvent des témoins de
très bonnes volontés mais qu'ils se
trouvent pour rappeler notamment dans la
fertile deal a été notamment coincé dans
un premier temps parce qu'un témoin six
mois plus tard prétendu avoir entendu
les enfants crier et trois heures après
la mort en riait tellement trois heures
avant elle s'est trompée elle entendue
toute autre chose c'est ça qui a fait
basculer pour les procès donc méfiance
pour les témoignages mais qui peuvent
être de bonne foi mais pr et rodez alors
j'ignore ce qu'il en est a priori même
d'avaler intelligente le vendredi
si ce n'est pas lui quand les parents et
la soeur est ce qu'ils ont mis dans ce
qu'ils ont dit liste est ce qu'ils ont
et l'affection
jeudi nous nous volontairement
collectivement les parents la soeur le
beau frère et moi même continuons de
penser peut-être à tort mais continuons
de penser jusqu'à présent n'a pas été
démenti par l'anc est que même d'aval
connaissait son assassin ils sont pas
prier et que c'est le prime d'un proche
mais approche sape est un client de la
banque où il travaillait ça peut être un
voisin
ça peut être un ami ça peut être
quelqu'un de sa parentèle et il ya donc
effectivement d'autres d'autres pistes
envisagées que celle de son mari et puis
je sais pas si c'est l'occasion de le
dire un mot mais il le faut il faut
absolument dans l'intérêt de toutes les
familles que la personne qui s'est donné
la mort dans le village de ce moulin le
13 janvier
il faut que l'on ait la preuve
scientifique par l'adn qu'il n'y a aucun
lien entre ces personnes et à la mort
des élections ne valent pas à ma
connaissance pour l'instant cette piste
n'est pas refermé si le côté du pic
affirmé l'avoir posée il disait que
cette piste-là qui est confirmée il
faisait le point presse pour démentir
tout lire justement parce qu'il n'y a
aucun il affirmé alors j'ai bien entendu
le communiqué de monsieur manuel du pic
pour qui j'ai le plus grand respect
notamment du fait qu'il a un homme de
main de maître mener les investigations
techniques dans la mort d'alexis sial de
valve mais je suis comme saint thomas je
crois et qu'il n'ya pas de lien
lorsqu'on a réalisé un comparatif adn
sur la dépouille du défunt des poulains
avec les traces de dr retrouvée sur la
scène de crime de jour j'aurai le
rapport entre les mains qui me dira que
ces adn ne sont pas comme je croirais
tout à fait que deuxièmement des ce
moulin n'a pas de rapport
donc les comparer son adn ne sont pas
fêté à ma connaissance elle ne sont pas
en fait
eh bien je j'ai la liberté de penser
qu'il faut refermer également cette
porte et on termine avec ça mais qu'on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui se contenter
d'un compassion disons les propos vous
avez un doute aujourd'hui par par cette
piste le timing semble étrange par
exemple je dis qu'il faut vérifier les
adn qu'aujourd'hui c'est très facile de
vérifier laden d'un mort et crade et end
une morte et qu'il n'ya pas de lien du
tout et bien que cet homme se rompe et
sa famille mais que pour l'instant tant
que ces comparatifs n'ont pas été portés
à notre connaissance ont réalisé à ma
connaissance elle n'a pas été il est
peut-être un peu prématuré de dire que
ça n'a aucun on a vu pire
alexia les parents est au courant ça
est-ce que c'était un problème vous
parlez des preuves de groupe le
récurrent alors je pense que je sais pas
ce que ça a été publiée que madame
d'aval souhaite avoir un enfant
puisqu'elle légitime parce que sa soeur
venait d'en avoir un et qu'elle voulait
également d'un enfant penser que de vous
quelque chose comme de très banal et que
comme les choses étaient peut-être un
peu difficiles à venir ou un peu retardé
eh bien elle en avait conçu une certaine
tristesse mais ça les parents les
paroles ça mais mais comme c'est
toujours le cas quand on a un désir de
maternité un désert de maternité
important ça les parents le sommet mais
on soit c'est très banal ça me prend
elle pas de disputes à répétition entre
du moins pas au point que ce soit porté
à connaissance des parents ou que ça
devienne alarmant et qui étant
symptomatique que des tiraillements
là-dessus certainement comme dans tous
les couples qui sont confrontés à ça ça
va très bien mais de là à ce que ça
devienne symptomatique nous on pense que
c'était des tiraillements
asymptomatiques attend comme arid alex
est entre les mains des enquêteurs on
voulait clairement qu'elle aille
jusqu'au bout de cette piste avec le
mari ah bah oui je le dis très
sincèrement mais je ne crois vraiment
profondément je souhaite de tout coeur
pour mes clients et pour monsieur d'aval
qui puisque sorti un mercredi et que le
parquet de besançon publie un communiqué
en disant qu'à ce stade aucune charge
n'a été retenue contre lui je le
souhaite vraiment pour mes clients comme
pour lui parce que si monsieur navale
qui est présumé innocent appel qui
victime qui est partie civile ce soir
toujours les gardes à vue ne sens pas le
statut y en a une chance pas de statut
juridique dans cette mine m6
par impossible mercredi matin on
apprenait qu'il est mis en examen pour
une infraction pénale qui peut être
variable s'appelle moeurs après pour
assassinat ça peut être pour non
dénonciation de crime
ça peut être pour modification de la
scène de crime ça peut être comme
coauteurs ou complices le panel est
large n'y a pas que comme auteur ça
serait pour mes clients une quelque
chose d'assez monstrueux et ça serait
bien pour leur film deuxième fois que de
savoir que l'homme en qui il avait toute
confiance et qu'ils ont associé à toutes
les étapes de leur deuil a une part de
responsabilité aussi
je dirais faible soit elle il parle
responsabilité pénale suffisante
prête-noms et ça ça serait une tragédie
est une possibilité que vous avez votre
expérience on écartait jamais qu'on peut
pas écarter
on ne peut pas l'écarter parce que ça
fait partie du champ des possibles et je
souhaite pas que ce soit ça
naturellement mais on ne peut pas
écarter dans ce type d'affaires non plus
des scénarios intermédiaires lesieu
d'avalasse us naval n'a rien dit c'est
navale a couvert quelqu'un c'est laval
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas mais
objectivement à la place qui est la
mienne
on ne peut pas sous peine de ne pas être
sérieux hier mais non j'ai car tout ça
c'est non non je dis qu'il ya pas de
raison de penser à ça mais que ça fait
partie des choses pas si c'est la vie de
l'opération chirurgie blier chose au
père et aucun risque n'est vraiment
qu'un rythme mais je n'exclus pas lié à
l'accident cardiaque pendant les stasi
je dois vous dire que en l'état ça
n'arrivera pas mais ça peut arriver là
je dis ça n'arrivera pas mais simple
aurait dit que les proches
on imagine qu'ils sont pas intrigué par
ce trajet la disparition s'il est avéré
s'il est avéré mais vous savez c'est pas
mal moi je ne connais pas je ne connais
pas la vie privée et des jeux on peut
aussi ressortir la nuit parce que vous
êtes disputé que votre copain votre
copine parce que vous êtes promus en d1
ce canapé parce que vous avez gros sur
le coeur vous allez coucher ses beaux
parents
j'en sais rien c'est pas parce que l'on
sortait l'anille ce que vous a oublié
quelque chose ailleurs je ne sais pas
c'est pas pour autant vous êtes un
assassin heureusement donc sais je sais
pas ce qu'il en est cet élément ou mais
à priori même d'aval apathiques les deux
m'ont dit que je sache vous espérez
avoir ces éléments
voilà la main rapidement with parce que
avec le placement en garde à vue
johnatan l'enquète prendre un coup
d'accélérateur très longtemps donc on y
verra beaucoup plus clair mercredi où il
ya rien de lui reprocher maladroite et
fin de l'épisode carnaval fin d'épisode
douloureux où il ya quelque chose à lui
reprocher début d'une autre vas y avait
une autre aventure pénale
mais là où des coûts menés on sera
beaucoup plus avancé mercredi
oui mais on en avait mes clients sont
des gens très patient très saine
comment dire mais très conscients ils
sont pas dans une bulle ils ne sont pas
coupés du monde et des réalités non
qu'il soit tentant ce que l'on dise leur
avocat et encore on avait très
clairement envisagée comme on dit enfin
tout ce qui était possible même si c'est
bien on peut envisager le pire sans pour
autant vous leur écran donc
ce matin la garde à vue ça leur est
tombé sur la tête parce qu'ils savaient
pas que ça soit aujourd'hui moi non plus
une personne de sava par les enquêteurs
et même le procureur de besançon
mais ce qu'ils espèrent maintenant c'est
que ça se termine pour lui comme pour
eux mais ronnie qui savoir quel est le
fils d un questionnement parfaitement
légitime
on a pu bien entendre que le samedi
physiquement il est il est certainement
la dernière personne à l'avoir vu est la
seule personne à avoir vu parce que vu
le timing de jeu de jogging pas quelle
heure elle partait mais relativement tôt
donc elle a croisé personne à part son
mari au kivu partant de chez elle si
elle est partie de chez eux
ce que j'ignore mais il est la dernière
personne à avoir vu ça c'est sûr parce
qu'il fait pas de lui un coupable non
plus mais c'est une réalité mais vous
savez c'est pour ça aussi que c'est bien
qu'ils étaient placés en garde à vue si
ça permet de laver de tout je dirais de
toute l'interrogation rumeurs vous savez
très bien que dans ces dossiers là la
rumeur dit le mari a forcément à voir
parce que statistiquement dans ce type
de crime dans cette typologie de crime
il est vrai que nos 80 % quand la femme
est assassinée s'est marré responsable
et qu'on arrêtait assassiné c'est à fond
on le sait mais c'est une statistique
qui n'est pas exact et puis c'est
qu'après % des cas où 70% des cas mais
c'est pas 100 % des cas elle c'est pas
le mot mathématiques aux moyens font
donc c'est bien qu'ils soient aussi s'il
a rien à voir là dedans qu'ils soient
lavés de construction c'est bien pour
lui c'est de la peau du cul